okay so episode one of Chainsaw man is
finally here and in this video we're
about to break down everything you need
to know throughout this episode we were
introduced to a ton of new Concepts such
as Devils devil contracts and devil
hunters and today we're going to explain
what it all means while also giving you
a review of the plot and any small
details you might have missed just
before we get into it though I'll be
doing these reviews every week so I'd
really appreciate it if you hit that sub
button if you haven't already and as
usual drop a like as it does help out
the channel
alright so to set the scene episode 1 of
Chainsaw man is set all the way back in
Japan of 1997 in an alternate reality
where these creatures called Devils
exist what makes these Devils special is
that they each have their own unique
abilities as they each represent one
thing that humans are afraid of for
example the zombie devil that we see
later on is a representation of
Humanity's fear of zombies and the more
people are afraid of zombies the more
powerful it gets by contrast the Tomato
devil represents human sphere of
tomatoes and as you can imagine it's a
pretty weak devil since not many people
have this particular fear now at the
beginning of the episode we're
introduced to denji who's a young devil
Hunter and someone who's desperately
trying to make money regardless of how
he gets it in the opening scene he walks
to work with pachita who's his pet devil
and he recounts how he's literally been
selling his own organs to make extra
cash so far he sold his kidney one of
his nuts and his right eye hence why
he's wearing an eye patch for like 90 of
the episode on top of that denji has a
second job cutting trees that makes him
around 60 000 Yen a month but to explain
why why he needs the money this badly we
need to examine his backstory years
earlier when denji looked to be around
10 years old his dad owed millions of
yen to this old gangster from the Yakuza
before the debt could be paid though his
Dad decided to hang himself meaning the
responsibility of paying it was passed
down to his young son this explains why
when denji's father is buried the old
man tells him to have 700 000 ready by
the next day or else he's going to be
chopped up a threat like that is
basically a death sentence since even
denji knew there was no way he'd be able
to make that much money in such a short
space of time just when it seemed like
things couldn't get any worse a tiny
devil dog then appeared from behind this
tree with a roaring chainsaw sticking
out of his head one of the rules of this
universe is that Devils can heal
themselves by drinking human blood and
so in all likelihood the chainsaw devil
intended to hurt or potentially even
kill denji when it first appeared
however due to pachita's pre-existing
injuries he collapsed on the ground
before he could do anything leading to
the most important decision of denji's
entire life In This Moment he realizes
that he and his devil should help each
other because as things currently he's
done they're both going to be dead
within a day instead of just accepting
that fate he offered potato a contract
in which the devil gets to regenerate by
drinking his blood in exchange for
helping to save denji from the Yakuza
chapter 17 of the manga confirmed that
contrast between a devil and a human are
binding so as long as denji performed
his side of the deal then Vegeta would
literally die if he weren't back on the
agreement this meant that once he drank
the blood the two of them were bound
together at least until denji was safe
from the Yakuza although the contract
could also be broken if either of them
was to die following that the next day
he uses his new pet chainsaw to slice
through the body of a devil possibly the
Blobfish devil if I had to guess and by
doing this denji proved to the old man
that he could be a devil Hunter this was
good news for him given that devil
corpses are incredibly valuable on the
black market and by going down this path
his father's debt could be repaid over
time now back in the present day of the
series despite working for the Yakuza
for years dengie still owes them over 38
million yen which is why he's been
trying all these different methods to
get money in the end though hunting
Devils is still the most reliable job he
has and together with pachita they
brutally slice up the Tomato devil early
in the episode when the old man then
arrives he offers Dengue over a hundred
thousand yen more than usual presumably
due to the courts being so huge but his
excitement doesn't last long as he gets
hit with a bunch of extra charges for
example the Yakuza deduct money for
admin fees management costs debt and a
bunch of other things and by the end
Angie's left with a fraction of his
original reward as if that wasn't bad
enough once he uses this amount to pay
for his water bill and other debts he's
left with the equivalent of 12 US
dollars to survive one for the rest of
the month for any normal person this
would be a ridiculous thing to be
expected to do but notice how Genji
doesn't even look that surprised after
years of living in poverty he's at the
point where being this broke isn't even
strange evidenced by how casually he
tells pachita that their dinner is a
slice of bread I think From denji's
perspective this miserable lifestyle is
only bearable because he has Vegeta as
is their relationship that allows him to
remain kind of upbeat even when trapped
in this never-ending death now before we
move on there's two important things you
should mention starting with this
conversation between the old man and one
of his minions during this interaction
he wonders if Dengue is fit to be a
devil Hunter to which the boss replies
by reminding him that real devil Hunters
would never sell corpses to the Yakuza
this statement was relevant since to me
it was hinting at the appearance of the
public safety devil Hunters who were
Bound by regulations from the Japanese
government in comparison to them denji
is essentially a criminal because not
only is he working for the Yakuza but
his contract with patita is actually
illegal the manga confirmed that humans
in Japan can't make contracts with
Devils unless it's been sanctioned by
the authorities by a typical denji
fashion he just kind of did it anyway
the second thing I wanted to mention is
how the Yakuza openly treat denji like a
dog which directly relates to the title
of the episode at first it's easy to
think that the title dog and Chainsaw is
a reference to pachita who is very
clearly a chainsaw dog however the title
is also referring to denji who's
perceived by everyone else as a dog who
always does what he's told in this clip
the Yakuza gangster gives him 100 yen to
eat a cigarette similar led to how you
might give a dog a treat so that they
listen to commands and later on the old
man straight up Compares him to a dog
for his loyalty considering that by the
end of the episode he then turns into
chainsaw man the title dog and Chainsaw
could equally apply to denji as much as
it applies to pachita anyhow switching
over to their home in the woods the two
of them live in a tiny shed overlooking
the city where we see them eating that
single slice of bread in a kind of
tragic moment he tells pachita that he
recently learned that it's normal to
have jam on bread instead of just eating
it dry but for them that type of
normality is nothing more than a dream
as long as he has this crashing debt
there's no hope of him having a normal
existence which sucks because it also
means he'll never get to go out with a
girl like he says he can't exactly
invite a girl around to his Shady
looking cabin in the woods and he also
never has any leftover money to take
girls on dates for those reasons his
chances with the ladies are virtually
non-existent which is why one of his
main aspirations is to get with a girl
before he dies in dengie's mind that
would be him achieving his ideal life
and this scene was a perfect example of
his relationship with Vegeta trapped in
their hopeless situation denji is a
dreamer who passes the time by
fantasizing about his perfect life while
pachita is the ultimate listener who
genuinely cares what he has to say in
that sense they are happy just being
with each other because their friendship
is the one thing that makes it worth
continuing in this inescapable cycle of
death as they then try to get some rest
denji's hunger distracts him to the
point where he can't sleep and the
longer he stays awake the more he thinks
about his finances which then makes
sleeping impossible to try to get around
this he starts describing to petite to
what he'd like to dream about where the
typical things including eating bread
with Jam flirting with a girl and
playing video games basically normal
teenager stuff for the most part soon
after he finishes talking though denji
coughs up a serious amount of blood and
this is a consequence of a heart
condition that was passed down to him
from his mother the fact pachita was so
short indicates that this might be the
first time Genji has had these symptoms
and he goes on to reveal that his mother
died coughing up blood just like he's
doing the way I see it this heart
disease is meant to symbolize that under
normal circumstances denji was destined
to die a relatively young death and
he'll never live to be old enough to be
free of his death from the Yakuza
however it's his relationship with
pachita that allows him to avoid this
Destiny which becomes clear by the end
of the episode when he gets a brand new
heart before we get to that though in
the middle of the night the Yakuza boss
randomly bounced on the door asking them
to hunt another devil and after a Scenic
car ride with a few nice shots from
above he drives him to this old
abandoned warehouse this Warehouse is
supposedly where the devil is meant to
be but even Genji seems confused why one
would be in such a remote location as
the boss then silently walks down this
dark hallway out of nowhere Yakuza Thug
ambushes denji and patrizia from behind
literally stabbing them through the back
the Betrayal In This Moment was pretty
sudden and unexpected so to explain why
it happened we need to examine the old
Mass motivations to put it simply he
wanted the Yakuza to keep growing and
make more money and he believed they
could do that by making a contract with
a strong Devil by gaining a devil's
power there'd be even less people who
could stand against them but the old
man's big mistake was that he made a
contract with the zombie devil
specifically at as you would expect from
a devil with a name like that his
ability is that he can turn humans into
zombies who then have no choice but to
follow his commands in that way the
Yakuza inadvertently turned themselves
into his personal servants and so when
they attacked engine pachita they were
actually carrying out his orders now you
might then be wondering why zombie has a
problem with these two seeing as he
doesn't even know them and the answer is
that as a devil he naturally has an
intense hatred for devil Hunters it's
likely that at some point the old man
mentioned they had a devil Hunter
working for them and so once the zombie
took control of the Yakuza he ordered
them to set denji up what follows this
was by far the hardest to watch scene of
the entire episode as an exhausted then
he limps away from a horde of zombie
gangsters before being knocked down and
repeatedly stabbed in the manga this
scene fought relatively clear because it
was over within a couple pages but here
the anime really takes time to make you
feel uncomfortable as the way he's being
stabbed is super slow and excruciating
and actually hearing him scream made the
whole thing very unsettling One Thing
Worth highlighting is that as they were
killing him he mentions how he was
wasn't even asking to be rich he
literally just wanted a normal existence
and this kind of emphasizes how tragic
his life has been because you know both
his parents are dead he's been forced to
pay off this debt that wasn't even his
originally and now he's being murdered
before even having the chance to live a
normal life anyway after the zombies
finished turning him to pieces the
remains of both devil Hunters are thrown
into the dumpster and at this stage
denji is 100 dead pachita himself is
barely hanging on to life as well but by
chance a small drop of denji's blood
trickles down into his mouth as we
already established human blood has
regenerative powers for devils and as
Vegeta slowly opens his eye we get a
flashback to when they were tree cutting
to make some extra money during this
flashback denji acknowledges that one
day he might die fighting against devils
and he wonders what would happen to
pachita in that scenario in theory the
chainsaw devil might starve to death or
he might be killed by another devil
Hunter but after thinking about it Genji
does come up with a solution generally
speaking there are devils out there who
have the potential to take over the dead
body of a human and in the manga these
type of devils are referred to as fiends
becoming a fiend has several downsides
mainly that the devil loses most of
their power and they lose the ability to
make contracts but in certain situations
it can be beneficial for example the
devil gets a whole new mostly human-like
appearance meaning there's a chance for
them to start a new life this is why
denji gets petite to the permission to
do this to him and his hope is that if
he does die Batista will possess his
body escape from the Yakuza and live a
normal life like they always talked
about however as his body starts being
pieced back together both of their
Spirits manifest inside of the dumpster
for one last conversation during this
exchange it becomes clear that Vegeta is
not taking over denji's body but rather
he's making a new contract between them
in this new deal pachita gives denji his
devil heart in exchange for denji being
the one to live their dreams of a normal
life by gaining a devil heart dengey's
body is able to fully regenerate just
like a devil's word and in the protest
he regains a ton of body parts the eye
that he sold earlier comes back his
heart condition is no longer an issue
given that he has a brand new heart and
on top of that we can assume his missing
kidney and testicle returned as well
additionally he has a quote coming out
of his chest which as you probably
notice is the same chord pachita used to
have for a tale seeing that denji
resurrected the zombie devil then sends
his minions to kill him for a second
time and this moment was pretty
interesting up until now denji had
always been dreaming about having a
normal life and from his perspective the
people in the Yakuza already had
everything a person could want because
of that he was confused why they wanted
even more power by making this contract
with the zombie devil but eventually he
comes to the realization that no matter
where people are in life it's natural
for people to fantasize about having
things even better in that sense
dreaming is a perfectly natural thing to
do which is why he doesn't judge the
Yakuza for making this contract but on
the flip side although he's not judging
them they are still standing in the way
of the dreams that he wants to
accomplish for that reason he pulls the
chord poking out of his chest almost
like he knew exactly what it would do
because within seconds he transforms
into actual chainsaw man with petite's
heart inside him denji has gained the
powers of the chainsaw devil and he
naturally uses these new abilities to
rip through the horde of zombies the
animation on his chainsaws was virtually
Flawless in my opinion and the whole
sequence didn't really hold back when it
came to the amount of blood during this
massacre the zombie devil tried to fight
back against Genji but ended up getting
sought in half and what was interesting
is that the Yakuza still stayed in their
devil forms even after the zombie Devil
Himself was dead as denji then continues
to wipe them out one by one he realizes
that if he kills all of them then he'll
be free of his death since neither the
old man or anyone else would be alive to
collect it this would enable him to
finally start living his dreams which is
why he keeps going until he's the only
one left standing episode 1 then comes
to an end the next morning with a car
full of Public Safety devil Hunters
pulling up to the warehouse leading this
group is makima who's probably the most
recognizable character from the series
and the reason they arrived here was to
capture the zombie devil what they
weren't expecting was to find a bunch of
zombie corpses with chainsaw man
standing in the middle and at first this
guy assumes that denji is also a devil
thanks to makima's amazing sense of
smell though she can tell that he
doesn't quite smell like a devil or a
human as denji then begins to fall down
he innocently asked makima for a hug
which is a throwback to the manga when
he mentioned how one of his dreams was
to hug a girl before he died in episode
1 they kind of changed this line to make
it sound like he wanted to score with a
girl before he died which has a lot of
different meanings
um but I guess whichever version you
look at the fact is touching a girl in
any way is something he's always wanted
to happen following this hug his
chainsaw parts start to melt away and
makima gives him two options for what
happens next either option number one
she treats him like a devil and kills
him which is her job or option number
two she keeps him as her human
essentially the choice is either he dies
or he becomes makima's pet aphidenji
this was a super easy decision if he
picks option number two then for
breakfast he'll get to have butter with
Jam salad coffee and maybe even dessert
and uh yeah compared to the dry bread
that he was used to this is a dream come
true and it's why he accepts option
number two before we end the video one
thing I didn't find time to imagine was
the very opening shot of the episode
which was a Dream from the first person
perspective of denji himself as he walks
through a random Alleyway he comes
across a locked door but as he goes to
open it this is what wakes him up I
don't really have much to say about that
at this point since it's not really
relevant to the plot just yet but in
future episodes we will Circle back to
this with that said that was my
breakdown for the first episode of
Chainsaw man and as far as an adaptation
goes this was as perfect as you could
expect that's not me saying the story is
perfect although it is really good but
what I mean is that when you compare
what's on the page to what's on the
screen the adaptation brings genuine
life into it especially the facial
expressions and the small bits of filler
that were added to make certain scenes
more impactful personally when you take
absolutely everything into account I'd
give this episode a 9.8 out of 10 but do
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below also if you like
this video then I'd appreciate if you
hit that sub Button as well and until
the next one peace out